hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 6 video it was
really like a wildcat centric episode I
mean we've seen Ted grant before but
this focus more on the Wildcat aspect of
his character hype I name is
boxing-glove arrow there were a lot of
good things in this episode also a few
teasers for next week's episode that I
was a little surprised by then I'll
explain once we get to spoilers the real
big news that everyone was talking about
this morning was the official Black
Canary costume
The CW posted official promo art for
Kate Cassidy's Black Canary costume she
has blonde hair face mask everything and
she's using batons like police batons we
won't see it on-screen till episode 10
that'll be the second half of the season
so it'll be February before we actually
get to see it I'll say right now is that
I'm totally intrigued by it I think it's
a lot more practical than Sarah's and I
can't wait to see Kate Cassidy kick some
butt
that being said careful for spoilers
from episode 6 if you haven't seen it
yet but starting with top five moments
number five katana flashbacks we haven't
seen a whole lot from katana this season
she's messiahs husband in the flashbacks
you may have seen her as Yukio The
Wolverine movie so she's jumping from
the Marvel franchise to DC and we're
totally glad to have her katana is an
awesome character I do not think that
she will be wildung the spirit blade I
don't think that arrow is gonna get
really mystical like that but there was
a scene in the recent trailer they
posted with her wielding it in modern
day so we will see her on the show it's
her memory enhancing scenes like the
meditation scenes that provide the
connective tissue between the flashbacks
Roy and the Wildcats storyline it was
really an episode with three main
storylines you had the Roy killing Sarah
storyline he had the Wildcat storyline
and then you had the flashbacks more
China white teasers too in those
flashbacks don't you just wonder what
she's doing that's so important like
Amanda Waller has trouble tracking her
down so it's got to be something pretty
crazy I'll expect that to continue into
modern-day China white seems like one of
those villains that's gonna cross over
from the flashbacks to modern day we
know she's not dead because we saw her
in season 2 either way katana gonna be a
total badass when she shows up gonna cut
the out of some people maybe she'll
even teach Oliver how to use a sword
right now the only people we've seen
using swords in the show are Merlyn and
Thea
so Oliver's gonna have to up his game if
he's gonna go toe-to-toe with him
speaking of training number four
Laurel continues her training with
Wildcat again just inching her closer to
Black Canary
getting her to the point where she's not
afraid to go out on the
extracurricular activities at night you
know fighting crime she just hasn't got
to the point where she's working with
weapons yet like I said in the costume
she's got the police baton so at some
point she's gonna be practicing with
those like Oliver and Roy were in
episode 1 I know there are a lot of
people who are still really sad about
Sara dying but you have to remember she
was a temporary character she was only
gonna be a guest she was never gonna be
on the show for multiple seasons Laurel
has always been the lead female
character the real question though is
how she's gonna fit into the team
aerodynamic even given all the Roy stuff
that went on in the episode she has a
positive relationship with Oliver and
Roy like she doesn't hate him or
anything but team Wildcat and team arrow
are two different things at some point
they'll cross over but until then it's
just gonna be her and Ted off on their
own I wouldn't be surprised if Laurel
becomes wildcats call to action to put
the mask back on right now it seems like
he's still kind of given up on it given
up on being a vigilante a lot of you've
asked me about the canary cry - I think
this closes we're ever gonna get - that
was Sara's sonic device I don't think
that Laurel is gonna get dumped in a vat
of toxic waste or anything like that and
get special powers number three
Roy confesses to killing Sara I know it
was a big WTF seeing that dream sequence
at the end of the last episode the
explanation is is that he remembered
something in a false way or his memories
got mixed up that happens to people all
the time they're just called false
memories I like the way the arrow
doesn't throw big things away this is
all about Roy killing that police
officer when he was mirakuru doubt
during season two this is the first time
that they've followed up on that like he
killed someone in cold blood that's a
really big deal I'd be curious to know
if they were holding that for now like
if they knew they would pay it off next
season like they were gonna deal with it
right away
sometimes they plan stuff way far in
advance sometimes they figure it out as
they go along another really awesome
example of why the arrow riders are so
good is the fact that they did not drop
laurels addiction like she's an addict
she can't take pain meds it's a really
small thing but I was really happy when
Laurel mentioned it in the episode it
just means that they're not forgetting
about the consequences of being an
addict like she'll be dealing with that
for the rest of her life I think the
thing we're most surprised about was how
Laurel dealt with Roy confessing to
killing Sara I expected her to totally
freak out the fact that she did not just
means that the writers don't want you to
be confused about what her relationship
with team arrows
to be there will be no change even
though she's gonna continue training
it's gonna be a very positive
relationship they just don't want to
throw any doubt on that and remember how
I said characters were getting framed in
this episode like Wildcat got framed Roy
apparently also got framed based on what
we learned from the flashbacks someone
else with a bow killed Sarah and it was
not Roy which leads me to number two
Cupid and credit sequence hello lovers
is gonna have to wait till next week I
was actually kind of surprised we saw
her she showed up in a big crowd scene
and then we didn't see her again she was
in the trailer there are a whole bunch
of scenes with her arrows been teasing
her a lot next week is her big episode I
know I spent a lot of time talking about
Roy getting framed it's possible that
she is the one that killed Sarah I don't
know if they'll wrap that up before the
mid-season finale or if it'll continue
through based on the way they presented
Roy's argument and they dealt with his
storyline it makes it seem like they're
gonna wrap that up sooner rather than
later here's just a little bit on
cupid's backstory in case you haven't
heard about her before I'll talk mostly
about her in next week's episode but
here's just something to get you guys
ready
her name is Carrie Hartnell she was a
SpecOps soldier working for a top-secret
program called cobalt she volunteered
for a program that would make her
fearless but instead but in a comic book
twist it makes her have extreme emotion
you know that's the cupid also as a side
effect she got increased strength and
memory loss eventually she made her way
to Starling to find her ex-husband and
while she was fighting with him Green
Arrow shot him and killed him thinking
that he was abusing her thus began her
obsession with Green Arrow now that's in
the comics so obviously arrow on the
show is gonna do something a little bit
different but it'll be a situation
probably where Oliver did something to
save the character and then she became
obsessed with him she also developed an
intense hate for Black Canary but it
does explain the mirakuru like strength
of throwing arrows and the fact that
someone's going around killing a bunch
of people so again all signs just
pointing to Cupid being the actual
person that killed Sarah and my number
one moment
meet Wildcat so we known him as Ted
grant for a while like we saw him in the
first episode but now arrow is just
pulling the curtain back on another
potential team arrow member the dynamic
they're teasing is a lot different from
season two with Sarah and Roy joining
the team and when he comes out for the
first time I think it'll be on his own
to help Laurel out like
be the two of them doing something and
then eventually they'll team up with
team arrow the tea's at the end is that
she's just gonna be his sidekick Black
Canary is gonna be Wildcat sidekick of
all the awesome things that happened in
the episode I will say you know Oliver
vs Wildcat boxing match
totally awesome boxing club arrow could
have never predicted they would have
actually done that Stephen Amell said
after season two one of the biggest
things from the comics that he said that
he wanted them to try was the boxing
glove arrow and they totally did it it's
like doing the Babe Ruth thing and
calling your home run shot we're gonna
do the boxing club arrow someday I will
say thus far every promise that arrow is
made as a show it's delivered on if
you've been really excited by the big
reveals they've made this season so far
this is nothing like they have so much
more stuff coming let me know what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and after everything we learned do you
agree do you think that Cupid is the one
that killed Sara
overall I gave the episode an A - I
totally loved what they're doing with
the Laurel character like I said she's
meant to be the female lead on the show
so obviously she has to be a badass at
some point and they're just getting her
there as fast as possible I love it when
shows do not waste time I think arrow
can thank the flash for that there's
this like crossover effect where the
flash is just going straight to
superhero super power super fast and
it's been really successful for them so
I think that arrow is learning from that
even though arrow originated the flash
and everything the flash did it learned
from arrow so it's like both shows
learning things from each other there
was actually an interview that Marc
Guggenheim did recently where he said
that Thea and Laurel were two of the
hardest characters for them to write for
especially in season two and I think
they basically solved all their problems
with what they're doing right now
Thea totally gonna be me Deardon gonna
be kicking a whole lot of but Laurel
getting to Black Canary faster than we
ever thought and both of them between
them just have crazy demons and that's
really where you get your interesting
superheroes the superheroes with the
biggest demons are the most fun ones to
watch I just I really get the sense that
Laurel is gonna rage on some criminals
and wild cats gonna have to pull her off
I was also a big fan of Colton Haynes in
the episode I thought he was able to
stretch his acting muscles quite a bit
Stephen Amell said at one time he said
that it's actually it's really hard for
him to play Oliver when he's not really
serious like being the really grim
superhero is the easy part but that
comes really easy to them what's hard is
being vulnerable
in a convincing way and I thought Roy
did that yeah he basically thought he
was done with team arrow even if I never
thought they were gonna give up on him
for a minute I thought it was a good
performance there's definite bromance
developing between Oliver and Roy I mean
even though he's like his little brother
he's like the little brother that he
never had not that he is replacing Tommy
like I said next week's episode crazy
stalker Cupid probably gonna get some
more answers about Sarah if not flat out
completely answering the question about
who killed her be sure to subscribe to
get my video I'll try to add a little
bit more about her backstory from the
comics too in case you haven't seen it
you can click here for my arrow episode
5 video and you can click here for this
week's flash episode thank you so much
for watching so let's all high-five I
will see you guys tomorrow
you